we like each other yeah we like each
other kelly ripa and mark consuelos
could write
a detailed how-to guide when it comes to
keeping marriage hot
with a special chapter on online
flirting
he is incredible the live with kelly and
ryan
co-host hit up instagram recently to
share some pics of her family's past
halloween costumes
ending on this shot that's mark and
their family friend
bruce bozzi dressed as john baker and
frank poncharello from the tv show
chips and mark well
he's rocking some very tight pants that
leave
little to the imagination uh we can't
talk
i'll tell you later naturally fans had a
lot to say about it
so that's when the 49 year old riverdale
star slid
into the comment section to explain
quote full disclosure
i believe that's definitely a shadow
that's causing that bulging effect
pretty sure that's when kelly chimed in
responding quote
um baby are you seeing shadows
sure asking about you no we we segued we
segway
but this is definitely not the first
time mark and kelly who have been
married for 24 years
have hit us with some epic verbal pda
online
we try we inspire each other we inspire
each other
earlier this month the 50 year old
daytime talk show host shared
this shot of her man shirtless in bed
alongside the caption one year ago and
still
a full hump day mood this man eats pb
and j
peanut butter and jelly equals six
six-pack abs
noted mark also celebrated kelly's
milestone 50th b
day earlier this month posting a few
shots of his wife and writing happy
birthday to my little ray of sunshine
i love you sexy i'm the luckiest woman
in america
i hope all the girls that were mean to
me in high school are watching this
right now the lovebirds are currently
living apart as the 49 year old actor is
quarantined in canada filming the new
season of riverdale under covet 19
protocols
but back in april they opened up about
their sex life on
sirius xm radio andy and revealed the
secret to keeping it hot
nearly a quarter century into their
marriage
i think we we found each other at the
right time in our lives
we were really young like we were
pliable to each other
we were we really like we learned each
other well yeah and
um and and so and with that comes a
certain level of comfort
and confidence and experimentation
and just we have fun we enjoy yeah
yes no yeah i'm sorry
[Music]